three two wait there's a food processor  hey what's up everyone my name is Tui  and welcome to a whole new season of  making it big the show where I turn your  favorite foods giant what oh my God this  is so big oh I'm a chef and content  creator I share really easy to follow  recipes most of them being Vietnamese  recipes because this is so much flour  this next step is going to be insane  everything that I do basically revolves  around food it's definitely safe to say  that I love food and I love my culture  I'm really proud of myself  I'm taking some of my favorite recipes  whether it's my own or Classics that I  grew up eating and making it big this is  going to be huge I knew it was gonna be  big but this is big make sure to  subscribe and follow me for updates  because you don't want to miss out on  this season